good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world you are waking up to
the papers this morning and you could be
forgiven for thinking we've gone back in
time to the seventies with strike
headlines aplenty that was the winter of
discontent now the season might be
different but the sentiment is still
very much the same on the eve of the
biggest rail strike in a generation and
warnings other workers could follow
their lead we'll ask the chief secretary
to the treasury that's simon clark what
the government is going to do about it
also on the show the shadow transport
secretary louise hague who will also
talk to the unions who in the form of
the deputy general of the tuc who says
that ministers are inflaming tensions
and the pcs general secretary mark
zuwatka who's backing the right to
strike it's monday the 20th of june
the summer of discontent looms on the
eve is the biggest rail strike in a
generation warnings now that teachers
doctors and airport staff could go down
the same track
i'm here at king's cross station in
central london where commuters are
preparing for a week of heavy disruption
angry depressed and losing sleep a new
sky news poll reveals how many more of
us are worried about the cost of living
it's just so hard having to get up every
day and put a great face on things when
all i'm doing on the inside is just
falling apart
firefighters in spain and germany are
battling blazes caused by a heatwave
experts are linking to climate change
starved by war millions face famine
across the horn of africa after years of
drought and now the impact of war in
ukraine we report from somaliland
the ball there may be thousands of miles
away from these markets but it's pushing
up the prices of grain and fuel to
unprecedented levels making the impact
of the drought
even worse
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning
the swimming ruling about transgender
athletes that's making waves we'll speak
to the founder of transgender trend
about what her views on protecting young
children are
bad
[Music]
records breaking records why ed sheeran
is celebrating this month
[Music]
gotta love a bit of ed haven't you first
thing in the morning now the winter of
discontent remember that it might be the
season of summer but the headlines hark
back to the 70s today on the eve of the
biggest rail strike in a generation the
tuc says ministers are inflaming
tensions and now there are warnings that
teachers and doctors could also strike
too over the coming months
more than 50 000 train workers are
expected to strike across the week
strikes will take place this tuesday
thursday and saturday but severe delays
are expected all of the week many
companies are telling people to avoid
traveling entirely workers in england
will be striking but services in
scotland and wales will also be impacted
these are all the companies affected
but network rail says just over one in
five of the normal number of trains will
run and they'll start later and finish
much earlier than usual the rmt union
leading the strike argue that its
members have experienced pay freezes
threats to jobs and attacks on their
terms and conditions
we used to take training saturday and
sunday so it's going to be it's going to
be it's going to really affect us but i
think that people should you know be
heard and if they want more pay for what
they do i don't see why they should you
know not strike but if they want to
strike for better conditions then that's
good for them but
i lose that as a result so no i don't
have much sympathy
well xing is standing by at king's cross
in central london for us this morning
morning shingi how are people feeling
there this
morning morning k you get the sense
which is similar to some of the people
you spoke to earlier there's a bit of
frustration but also a bit of
understanding about why these strikes
are taking place they're of course being
led by rmt union who are calling for pay
rises in line with inflation as well as
an end to proposed job cuts but with
these strikes come massive disruption
people will be trying to take exams
tomorrow who may need trains there'll be
people who need hospital appointments
who may need to use the trains as well
and then later on in the week if the
strikes on thursday and saturday go
ahead you have massive events like
glastonbury and the british athletics
championships it's a highly political
issue it's highly divisive and people
here have no doubt will no doubt have
opinions on on these strikes thanks for
joining us now chief secretary to the
treasury um in the studio as you can see
and that's simon clark hi good morning
thanks for joining us what's the
government going to do about it well we
hope very much that uh ongoing talks
between the employer and the the unions
will make
progress today and clearly
from our point of view we want to see a
resolution to uh to this issue but we
obviously want to see a resolution that
works for everybody and that needs to
work for real workers but critically it
needs to work for passengers and the
taxpayer as well and that's what
underpins this whole process we need a
railway which is both sustainable in
terms of its costs but also in terms of
the service it provides to the public
and at the moment we don't have that the
the taxpayer supported the railway
industry very substantially during the
pandemic we're now coming out of that we
need the railway to be as i say a
sustainable uh force in our country it
isn't those changes need to be secured
as part of this wider negotiation so
what are you going to do to stop the
strike well as i say we continue to to
make sure that those talks uh have the
support from government that they need
but ultimately this is a matter between
the employers the train operating
companies and network rail and the trade
unions and the government doesn't sit uh
directly as a part of those talks for a
very good reason
we don't intervene in the specific
process between an employer and the
unions representing employees but we are
there to provide uh the support uh and
the enabling framework for those talks
to succeed
but if you don't get involved the
country is going to grant you a halt for
a week
well
ultimately okay we don't we we we don't
uh control all the levers that need to
be uh
that need to be held here as the the
employer the employer is network rail
and the train operating companies they
are the ones who need to drive the
program of reform to make the railway
sustainable we we don't own the railways
uh ourselves and it wouldn't be right
for us to substitute ourselves for the
role of the employer we recognize these
strikes are a huge inconvenience for
millions of people i absolutely want
them not to go ahead but it isn't the
case that we can put ourselves into the
hot seat in place of the legal employer
now you say you're not getting involved
with the negotiations but then you say
something like this at the weekend what
we can't do is have unrealistic
expectations around pay which do in turn
prolong and intensify this inflation
problem because we all want it to end
and the way it will end soonest is if we
are sensible about pay so you are
getting involved well that uh that my
comments there were in the context of
the wider public sector pay uh review
bodies process which is taking uh taking
place at the moment which will determine
pay for the people who the government
does employ directly that is to say
uh our teachers our nurses our police
doesn't apply to them it sets it sets an
overall framework which is important for
employers to understand which is that
obviously public sector pay discipline
really matters here we have an inflation
problem in this country as indeed is
common across the western world after
the pandemic if we don't want that
problem to either intensify or prolong
itself then we need to be sensible
around pay awards if we give awards
which are uh above inflation in this
landscape then we are in a really
difficult place in terms of bringing
down inflation which in turn obviously
in turn obviously is driving a cost of
living but that's not what the rmt's
asking for they're asking for seven
point one percent and inflation looks so
it'll be riding at something like 11
well the the issue the issue we need to
secure for the railways is about making
sure that you have a sustainable offer
on pay but also linked to productivity
reform as well because the railways are
are not run as efficiently as they could
be there are all sorts of practices
there which are seriously outdated which
uh which make the railways a bit more
expensive to operate but also less
efficient in terms of their operation
than they otherwise ought to be and so
there's a variety of
a variety of things that need to change
whether that be in ticket offices or in
terms of maintenance or in terms of uh
different different unions not really
offering the smoothest possible service
when it comes to
how they how they operate uh which do
need to which do need to change if the
taxpayer and the fair payer is to get
the the right deal so it's the right
idea then to um for effectively rail
workers to suffer a pay cut well in the
current situation with with with
inflation which is a which is which is a
real issue we do have to be very very
sensitive if we start having pay awards
which take us uh close to double digits
then we are going to see this problem
prolonged and that is that is just the
economic reality of where we find
ourselves at at the moment and is that a
yes then well
i'm not i'm not as i say i i'm not the
the legal employer uh in in in in this
dispute and so i'm not going to
substitute myself for network rail for
the train operating companies but we do
absolutely need to have an understanding
across the wider public sector that we
cannot have inflation-busting pay
increases because that will in turn
drive the problem we're trying to solve
how likely do you think it is that
strikes will go ahead
i fear it is uh likely that they will go
ahead uh clearly we will continue to uh
support the negotiations until such time
as there's there's no more uh time to
discuss but i think the public do this
we need to be aware there will be very
substantial uh disruption and it is
therefore sensible to make preparations
for that now you um want to tell us a
little bit about a cost of living
calculator which will reflect the
national insurance um and and how people
will be saving money or otherwise but at
the weekend we saw thousands of people
coming to central london to demonstrate
about the cost of living crisis is this
government tone deaf when it comes to
what's happening no absolutely not i
mean we we we are very confident that
the 37 billion pounds package of support
that we've put in place much of which of
course is yet to kick in because it will
be paid into people's bank accounts
throughout the course of the summer in
the autumn ahead will very substantially
help with the cost of living pressures
that families are facing and it's worth
1 200 pounds for roughly one in three uk
homes for most families it's worth at
least 550 pounds this year it is
something which is there to help people
look the trade the trade union movement
you know who are not uh it must be said
normally massive supporters of
conservative governments well we'll take
a look at the trade no no it's most
certainly all of these it's it's most
certainly not but it is fair to say that
i don't think this can be taken as a
snapshot of of mainstream britain this
is this is the the tea you see on a
march that is a very different uh group
of people to the wider public we all
recognize that there are there are real
challenges at the moment but it is this
government working to try and make sure
that we come out of the pandemic that we
grow the economy and that we manage the
public finances responsibly but the tuc
is representing lots of trade union
members of course and it does look as
though from reading the papers this
morning that more and more of those
trade unions will be balloting their
members to go on strike it looks as
though we are heading towards a summer
of discontent well look we have to see
what happens with uh the individual
unions what i'd emphasize is there is a
pay review body process that's in place
across government that's uh independent
of government so there are there are
independent groups of experts who
recommend
pay awards and it's then for individual
government departments to respond to
those for the workforce is concerned but
those those bodies are reporting
throughout the course of june and then
government departments will set up their
response in due course
from what i understand and it is early
days those rewards are coming those
awards are coming in at a sensible uh
level which is great it does mean that
there will be
good pay offers i think on the table for
public sector workforces it's important
that we wait and see what those uh
awards are when and then and then
obviously it will be for individual
workforces and the trade unions to
respond but i do think people have to
recognize if we're going to
you know forestall the evil of inflation
and inflation destroys savings it
destroys growth it damages any economy
where it gets the endemic grip then we
are going to have to show uh collective
society-wide responsibility and i think
i think that's a message which people
watching this program will understand
for people who are struggling to make
ends meet as it is and they look as
though they are realistically going to
have a pay cut given what's happening
with inflation so they are going to
exercise their democratic right
potentially to go on strike and as a
result you may well find yourselves
with a summer of discontent well we'll
cross uh more than that that that's a
possibility no
what i would say is
i recognize that there was there is
sacrifice involved in this situation
we've put in place a 37 billion pound
package of support to help to help
address it i'm not going to preempt what
the results of individual pay review
body processes will be or how the trade
unions will respond
as i said all i can do is emphasize the
government is trying in good faith to
manage what is a very difficult
balancing act between making sure that
people get the pay awards that they
deserve our public sector workers
genuinely do do it the most fantastic
job but this has to be set against the
wider responsibility i have the
government has to the public finances to
make sure they are sustainable we're
spending 83 billion pounds this year on
our debt interest payments after covid
we cannot afford to get into a situation
where we lose control of the public
finances and in turn all suffer unions
are disagreeing aren't they and they're
saying you know we're going to ballot
our members unless we get a real estate
you know with great respect to the trade
union leaders they obviously don't come
at this from a point of view of a uh
conservative government we we have a
mandate from the bishop public to to
manage uh the national finances sensibly
that's always in the end what a
conservative government is there to do
it is vitally important that as we come
out of this incredibly difficult
situation where we are facing the twin
headwinds of what's happened with covid
and now of course war in europe that we
that we do strike the right balance here
and when you're talking about public
sector pay are you suggesting given that
you're suggesting that potentially there
would be reasonable payoffs they will
match inflation i i'm not i'm not going
to preempt the results of the individual
pay review bodies but i think i think it
i think it is unlikely that they will
they will match the headline right of
inflation at the rates we're now seeing
but that is precisely the point i'm
making that if we try and match or
exceed inflation if we end up in a cycle
where everyone starts targeting uh the
levels that we're seeing now nine ten
percent that is going to be
unsustainable well i think the private
have to prepare for a totally
sector the private sector as well will
go through this okay i think i think the
point is very very few people are going
to be getting uh pay offers which which
are in double figures i think it would
be highly uh unsustainable if they were
to do so
um talk to me about airport chaos
because it is absolutely chaotic at the
moment at many of our airports is brexit
to blame
no i think what we're seeing here is the
result of the airline industry having
obviously massively contracted during
the pandemic and now it's facing this
surge of pent-up demand as things stand
back up
and
truth be told it isn't
resourced and manned for that challenge
that's why i think it is sensible that
what we're starting to see now is some
of the airports revising their schedules
for the summer season ahead because
frankly we can't have a repeat of the
scenes that we've been having at some of
our airports over recent
recent weeks and i know the transport
secretary ministers there have been
working very closely with the airline
industry to try and get into a more
sensible place because they are at the
moment offering flights they simply
can't honor and that is that is terrible
for passengers completely mental at some
of these airports at the moment um i
mean the chief executive ryanair says uh
is blaming the chaos on inflexible
post-brexit labor market and the ceo of
wizair says the uk's post-brexit
immigration policy is putting a lot of
strain on the labor market so they say
it's brexit well that i mean ultimately
i think the british people made their
views very clear on uh you know
unlimited immigration from the eu uh and
and and there were very good reasons why
we we voted to have a controlled
immigration policy
but but i do not i do not accept that
this is this is simply a direct pasture
effect from brexit what i would say is
this is a result of an industry which
massively slimmed down and
understandably so at a time when uh
flying was well known possible for a
year and a half two years it's now
massively expanded its operations and
the pressure is enormous and it hasn't
managed to align the two
we will do our part as government to try
and make sure that our side of things is
right from issues like passports to
border control
well and obviously while we're pouring
resource into this we're making sure
that the whole processes are as robust
as they can be but in turn the airlines
the airlines but the airlines need to do
their part of our part of things and
make sure that the flights that they're
actually offering can indeed be honored
and that's that's the key thing what
does pouring resource mean well it means
that we're making sure that all of these
departments whether that be uh the
border force or or pass or the passport
office have the resources they need to
manage this and as part of the spending
review we conducted last october we we
obviously made sure that all of our home
office infrastructure has the funding it
needs uh to do the job what do you want
to say to people who are waiting at home
who could be one of those 500 000 people
that are waiting for their passports
well
we all recognize the frustrations that
go uh that go with waiting for a
passport and the pressure that comes if
there's a holiday imminent what i can
say is that the government is working
flat out to make sure that people get
those in a timely fashion and as i
understand it the the
the the waiting times are coming down
which is really positive uh and that's
something we'll continue to prioritize
we're out of time sadly it's good to
talk to you thank you thank you for
joining us thank you as always uh let's
have a look what the papers are saying
my goodness the metro features the
upcoming rail strikes which the paper
says could be the biggest rail shutdown
in 30 years
the guardian says a failure by
government ministers to negotiate with
unions means strikes will go ahead this
week just hearing there from the
minister he also thinks that the strikes
will go ahead
rail union threat to strike for six
months is the headline on the front of
the daily telegraph the daily mail says
the rest of the summer could be affected
by strike action as unions threaten
walkouts by teachers nhs staff
barristers and postmen the times is also
leading with proposed plans for doctors
and teachers to strike this summer
this country is returning to the seven
years is the headline on the sun
referring to a summer of strikes and the
daily star says there is another
heatwave on the way thanks to the warm
air traveling up from spain
there you go front of the daily star now
as the cost of living crisis continues
to bite a sky news poll suggests that
almost a third of people feel more
depressed about their household finances
now than they did six months ago a
national mental health charity has
warned that people will die if funding
doesn't increase to match demands for
services
a warning this report from our people
and politics correspondent nick martin
contains references to suicide
susan lopez works full-time as a carer
but her pay is low and the hours are
uncertain
after all her bills are paid she says
there's often only a few pounds left to
live on i actually can't afford
to get the blinds it's just
newspaper for now
until i can afford it
susan says the rising cost of living
means her mental health has never been
so bad
it's just so hard having to get up every
day and put a brave face on things when
all i'm doing on the inside is just
falling apart
i don't want to be here anymore that's
honestly how i feel i just don't want to
be hearing them i've had enough life i
can't take it anymore i can't take
the fact that the cost of living anymore
it's just too expensive how we're going
to be able to afford to pay gas bills
and electric bills when
we're not making the money do it
susan's not alone a sky news poll has
revealed just how damaging this crisis
could prove to be to the nation's mental
health more than 60 percent of people we
asked said they felt more worried about
the cost of living than they did six
months ago
nearly a third said they were more angry
and a similar number said they felt more
depressed now
and one in five people said the rising
cost of living was affecting their sleep
we've just seen an awful rise in sort of
people just coming to the service what
all that emotional support for people we
try and help them sort of sort out the
finances get the right support put in
place contact councils food banks for
them and just try and get them figured
out and in the right place really we've
seen clients who sort of
their suicidality has increased a lot
related to sort of the worries that
they've got about the future and not
being able to cope at the moment
the government says it's providing eight
million of the most vulnerable
households with extra support this year
it says it'll spend an additional 2.3
billion pounds a year by 2024 on mental
health services
but susan says she's not had enough
support to help her through this
difficult time in her life the
government's all about making the rich
richer in the pool pool
that's in my eyes that
will put the taxes up will put the
national insurance up
it's not fair when people who work
because then they made it suffering they
made a struggle see i cried myself to
sleep every single night just
asking god to take me
because i don't want to be here
susan is now receiving one-to-one
support to help with her mental health
but this costs money and as this crisis
deepens this kind of help is likely to
be in high demand
nick martin sky news sunderland
and if you've been affected by any of
the issues raised in nick's report you
can of course contact the samaritans on
116 123
or email joe
samaritans.org joe at
samaritans.org and you can watch nick's
full report on mental health and the
cost of living crisis at 9 30 and
throughout the day here on sky news
and given what we were just talking to
the minister about we've just got some
breaking news uh from
easyjet they're saying they're cutting
more flights in the busy summer period
to help manage operational problems
including staff shortages in ground
handling and flight caps at london
gatwick and amsterdam the airline said
it's now expected its capacity in the
quarter to the end of jude to be around
87 of 2019 levels and its fourth quarter
to end september to be around 90 percent
adding that there would be a cost impact
from the disruption um so that from um
easyjet saying that there will be
problems and more flight caps at london
gatwick and amsterdam we've heard um
from whis air and also
from reiner who are blaming brexit for
the problems we heard there from the
minister a few moments ago saying that's
not the case at all it's the airlines
who've not scaled up quickly enough
still to come on the programme foie a
head of strikes across the country's
rail network this week joined by the
trade union congress deputy general
secretary that's paul novak
then speaking to the telegraph travel
editor claire evan to get her assessment
of the recent travel chaos in the uk
and at the top of the next hour we'll
get more reaction to those planned rail
strikes with labour's shadow transport
secretary that's louise hay
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you though and emmanuel
macron has lost his majority after
france's parliamentary elections
we'll have more on that and police in
brazil have identified five more
suspects in the murder of the british
journalist dom phillips and his local
guide bruno pereira officers want
officers want to speak to the group
about claims they helped hide the bodies
in the amazon they previously arrested
three other men in connection with the
killings one of whom has confessed to
the murders
the energy regulator of gem has proposed
new measures to protect consumers money
and stop energy suppliers from raising
customers direct debit payments by more
than necessary afghan afghan says the
measures are aimed at reducing the risk
of suppliers going bossed as well as
protecting customers from being
overcharged
speaking to the head of off gem that's
jonathan breely this morning for more on
the plans
president zielenski has predicted that
russia will intensify its attacks on
ukraine this week as kiev awaits a
decision on its bid to join the eu
his warning follows the european
commission recommendation to grand kiev
candidate status to join
and as far as emanuel macron is
concerned he's lost his majority as i
said in france's parliamentary elections
his centrist ensemble coalition remains
the largest party in the national
assembly but the hung parliament could
mean he'll face difficulty fulfilling
his domestic agenda marine le pen's
national rally saw an 11-fold rise in
its number of seats its best result on
record
most children in reception year in wales
will receive free school meals from
september it's the first stage in the
welsh government's plan to offer free
school meals to all primary school
children by 2024 in response to the cost
of living crisis
the english golfer matt fitzpatrick is
the new u.s open golf champion it's his
first major title he finished on six
under par after final rounds whoa 68 he
becomes just the fourth english player
in the last century to win the event and
was he not as cool as a cucumber
now the world governing body of elite
swimming has banned transgender athletes
from competing in women's events if
they've gone through any part of male
puberty
fina also said it will look at
establishing an open category for
swimmers whose gender identity is
different than their sex at birth
but some believe the ruling is
unnecessary
who do they think are going to compete
in those events they're the world
population of trans women is 0.25
even that 0.25 don't all play sports how
many you could hold it in a telephone
box
although a former olympic medalist
welcomed the ruling as a sensible move
leah thomas before she transitioned was
800th in the world and last year when
she won the nc2as um she beat three
olympic medalists from america that's a
massive improvement in one year don't
you think
and we'll be speaking further about this
topic to the founder and director the of
the transgender trend organization
that's stephanie davies ahri and stay
tuned for more on that throughout the
course of the show
meantime over the past few weeks we've
been bringing you updates about dame
deborah james who announced last month
that she's receiving end-of-life care at
her parents home in her battle with
bowel cancer
she's posted this on social media to
mark father's day
she there she is she um she spent the
day with her dad alastair and um in this
heartbreaking caption said her hair he's
brushing her hair because she no longer
has the strength
to brush it herself
well she's still proving an inspiration
to so many people her fundraising page
now standing at more than
6.7
million pounds raised so far for cancer
research uk you can go onto the just
giving page and support
dame deborah if you would like to
wildfires are spreading through
countries in europe as the continent
bakes in searing temperatures fire
fighters in spain are struggling to
contain wildfires as part of the country
experiencing temperatures of more than
40 degrees at least 18 villages have
been evacuated and military firefighting
units deployed with high temperatures
and dry and windy conditions expected
until wednesday
meanwhile germany has also seen a number
of forest fires over the weekend strong
winds have been fanning ablaze near the
town of troy britson about 30 miles
south of berlin prompting the evacuation
of three nearby villages
and weather experts are predicting a
summer of sunshine with the uk set to
basque in up to four heat waves
after an unsettled weekend forecasters
say the hot weather is soon to return
with temperatures expected to hit 28
degrees centigrade that's 82 degrees
fahrenheit this week now someone you may
have heard of who is playing at the o2
and wembley uh has been proving his
popularity once
[Music]
gotta love ed in the again the most
played artist of 2021 in the uk has also
claimed the year's most played single
with that one bad habits the pop
superstar is the first artist to claim
both accolades in two different years
having previously done the double in
2017.
love it
now freya's put some pictures together
for you today have a look at these this
is the image that we were showing you a
few moments ago lots of the papers
focusing on these piles and piles of
baggage at heathrow terminal 2 as flight
cancellations and delays continue and in
the corner there he is he's a pilot
helping out at edinburgh airport to get
luggage
onto the plane can you see he actually
got off the plane and started helping um
load the luggage in order that his
passengers could be on their way
um a different kind of pilot now in the
times take a look at this the spirit of
wartime enactment group posed as
american air crew at the duxford summer
air show this weekend love that
uh and the speaker of the house of
commons lindsay hoyle here he is with
his kitten in the telegraph he's named
after clement atlee the post-war labor
prime minister what a great picture that
is
lindsay hoyle there this image in the
express this morning from the blair and
safari park mum and dad liberty and phil
cradle their new baby
fear
glorious picture love that
and a last one from the telegraph this
morning bathers are pictured in rubber
rings in an artificial wave pool in
nanjing in china's zheng zhao province
yesterday it's pretty cool isn't it
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news in
last half an hour the chief secretary to
the treasury has told this programme he
thinks the biggest rail strikes in
decades can't be stopped from going
ahead simon clark warned commuters
should prepare for the worst and that
there would be substantial disruption
i fear it is likely that they will go
ahead uh clearly we will continue to
support the negotiations until such time
as there's there's no more uh time to
discuss but i think the public do this
we need to be aware there will be very
substantial uh disruption and it is
therefore sensible to make preparations
for that
joining us now from birkenhead is paul
novak to uc deputy general secretary hi
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us on the program this morning i know uh
that you're suggesting that the
government should uh adopt a more
positive uh approach to try to sort out
this strike it doesn't look as though
that's the case
no unfortunately it it it doesn't carry
and i'm on foot you know this strike is
not inevitable i think the rnt have
always been very clear that they think
that there's a negotiated settlement to
resolve uh the concerns that their
members have but you can't get that
negotiated negotiated settlement if the
government and employers insist on
imposing job cuts and pay cuts
unilaterally so i know talks are
happening this morning i would hope that
the government rather than talking up
these strikes uh actually get into the
room and and makes that you know helps
resolve the issues that be good for our
mt members but it'd be good for the
traveling public as well why should the
government do that it's not their job
well actually everybody knows that the
financial envelope that the train
operating companies and network rail are
working with has been set by government
and just to say okay i think the roots
of this dispute lie in that spending
review last year the government
announced it was going to slash funding
uh for rail
we used to meet government ministers
regularly during the pandemic to talk
about issues around uh rail myself and
all of the rail unions we had very
positive discussions didn't always agree
but positive discussions about how we're
going to help the industry emerge from
the pandemic but unfortunately we had
that spending review and since then the
shutters have come down i don't think
our unions have met a rail minister uh
since march of this year so that let's
let you know grand chaps need to stop
messing around everybody knows that he
could help resolve this dispute and i
think the government needs to take that
responsibility
how can he do that when the head of the
rimt says he wouldn't be seen dead
negotiating with the tory government
well i i don't think that's the case i
know i know mick lynch and i know the
other leaders of the rmt and i know that
they're very pragmatic and they'll sit
down and discuss with anybody if it
means getting a a fair resolution for
their members and they've always been
clear that the the solution to this
dispute lies in a negotiation but you
can't have what a negotiation what one
side goes into those talks saying well
what whatever happens you're going to
have a real terms pay cut and you're
going to lose two and a half thousand
jobs i mean if i was an rmt member i'd
be extremely concerned about that that's
why those 40 000 rail workers have taken
that very difficult decision uh to vote
for industrial action and so i hope that
the government and the employers will
come to the table positively listen to
the concerns of those rail workers these
are people who care about the service
that they provide they care passionately
about the rail industry they want to
serve the travel in public but they
can't do it when their pay is being
slashed and jobs are being potentially
lost
um yeah but grand chap says that he was
told by union bosses last month that
they wouldn't be seen dead negotiating
with the tory government is he
okay to be fair to be fair okay grand
shapes also said at the weekend that the
rmt had walked out talks on saturday to
attend the tvc rally and clearly that
wasn't the case there were no talks
scheduled for saturday so rather than
grandstanding uh what
chap should do is not negotiate over the
airwaves but around the table uh with
the unis and he needs to be you know be
clear that actually
our rail industry is going to need
support as we emerge from the pandemic
every government around the world has
supported its rail industry of course
passenger numbers aren't quite where
they were before the pandemic but we all
want a successful sustainable railway
and we have to think imaginatively about
how we do that let's remember during the
last two years the train operating
companies have taken 500 million pounds
worth of profits out of our rail system
let's have a discussion about that
before we talk about cutting the pay of
rail workers
um
we heard from the chief secretary of the
treasury simon clark on the show and
over the weekend saying that wage rises
would cause an inflationary spiral that
will take us back to the 1970s
and andrew bailey who is the governor of
the bank of england as you know says
that um workers need to show restraint
yeah well i have to say i i take both
those comments with a huge pinch of salt
to be honest with you i mean the
chancellor got up in front of the uh
the house of commons just a couple of
months ago i made it clear that
inflation in this country wasn't being
driven by uh wage increases for care
home workers or
workers or supermarket workers it was
being driven by
energy prices and you know i would like
andrew bailey and others to talk about
profits as well as wages give you one
example royal mail last year handed out
400 million pounds to its shareholders
and at the same time again told its work
is not to expect the real terms uh pay
increase there's got to be a balance and
that balance has got to work for working
people and it's no use talking about
wages if you're not also going to talk
about profits and the role of the
government as an employer as well
because obviously you know again the
government announced last year that it
was ending the public sector paid freeze
a few months later the prime minister's
telling public sector workers uh to
expect the real terms pay cuts i mean
they've got to get the story straight
and frankly their story at the moment
doesn't work for working people
is grant chap's the right guy for the
job
well listen i'm not going to comment on
whether he's the right guy for the job
or not what i want him to do is to do
the job he's got and that means helping
to resolve this dispute and that
you know i think me stepping up to the
plate and taking some responsibility
rather than spending your time touring
the tv studios and talking to newspapers
about how bad the rmt are and how
political they are and all the rest of
it get round the table and help resolve
this dispute
sansa's though you don't think he's the
right guy for the job
well it's like
i don't make ministerial appointments
okay and frankly the tuc deals with
whoever the minister of the day is or
whoever the secretary of state of the
day is what i want to do is is find a
situation where those 40 000 railway
workers get a decent pay rise don't have
job cuts imposed upon them and that we
actually work together to build a
successful sustainable railway uh in
this country the traveling public needs
that uh the people delivering the
service need job security you know there
is a way forward here but ministers need
to you know to find the key to unlock
the door
do you think that the strike is going to
go ahead
well i don't know i mean there are talks
happening um today and i think at the
end of the day not one of those 40 000
railway workers took that decision to
vote for strike action lately they're
all they'll all lose pay if the strikes
go ahead but i'm pretty sure they're
also very clear that they can't not go
ahead if the government doesn't step up
to the plate and take you know impose
job cuts impose pay cuts off the table
um we are hearing that other
workers as well uh certainly by their
unions are considering um balloting for
strike action we've made the comparison
this morning about the winter of
discontent are we heading for a summer
of discontent do you think
i i really just don't like those labels
to be honest with you okay because i
think what it does is it downplays the
real concerns of the workers that we're
talking about whether they be teachers
whether they be rail workers whether
they be postal workers these aren't
workers who are taking strike action for
the fun of it or because they're somehow
politically motivated the workers who've
got real concerns about things like pay
i mean we've had the biggest squeeze on
on pay and living standards in this
country for 200 years real terms wages
are lower than they were a decade ago
and you know i think a lot of our
members are just saying enough is enough
i can't afford to fill the car i can't
afford to do the wheatley shop i can't
afford to pay the gas bills you know
something's got to give and that's why
you know i would hope that employers and
governments take the concerns of their
workers seriously give people decent pay
rises
this year you know lots of those key
workers that were talking about across
the public and private sector really you
know went that extra mile during the
pandemic and what's their reward a real
terms pay cut come on surely britain can
do better than that and certainly the
government should be doing better than
that okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us
cheers thanks bye thanks a lot tomorrow
thoughts good morning morning kay well
look he the tuc say that these last
ditch talks happening today between the
rail companies and the rnt union may
avert the strike but the government are
pretty clear that that is very very
unlikely to happen the treasury minister
simon clark said people should prepare
for strikes prepare for a lot of
disruption because we expect there will
be 40 000 workers from 13 train
operators walking out this week that
will be the biggest walk out for 30
years and people who want to go to work
go to hospital appointments go to
enjoyable summer activities are going to
be unable to do so and it looks like the
government is going to be unable to do
anything about it they say it's not
their job to do anything about it and i
thought there was an interesting wider
warning for the public sector there and
from the treasury minister of course
we're going to see
bits of the public sector which have had
a pay free for many years now lifted but
now looking at you know inflation uh
running wild and very high energy bills
and hit the the message of simon clark
was essentially you can't have a pay
rise at inflation level because that
will fuel more inflation and he was
saying there will be sacrifice involved
for public sector workers tougher job as
they do they will have to put up with a
pay settlement that is below what their
expectations are and we'll see in the
next hour and tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock looking forward to it thank you
meantime aid agencies are warning of a
humanitarian catastrophe in eastern
africa due to drought and the impact of
the war in ukraine the blockade of
ukraine's ports has caused a global food
shortage and a sharp increase in prices
and in countries unable to grow their
own food the result could be devastating
for millions of people the horn of
africa is facing severe drought after
the rainy season failed for the fourth
year in a row with somalia and the
self-declared republic of somaliland
facing the worst drought in 40 years
almost 800 000 people have left their
homes in the countryside to seek help in
cities a group say the failed reigns
inadequate humanitarian funding and the
impact on prices because of the war in
ukraine have created a perfect storm
that could quickly lead to famine more
than seven million people are facing
high levels of food insecurity in the
coming months
and one and a half million children
under the age of five are facing acute
malnutrition
our international affairs editor dominic
wagon reports from mandera in the
self-declared republic of somaliland a
warning his report begins with images of
malnourished children receiving
treatment which viewers may find
distressing
[Music]
two-month-old muhammad is lucky to be
alive
born eight weeks premature in a village
all but wiped out by drought
deca his 17 year old mother traveled 400
miles to get him to hospital and didn't
think he'd make it
she was very very upset and worried
about her condition first time she came
she was worried like
he will die
he still looks desperately ill but
doctors say he should survive
many like him haven't
the ward is full they're putting
patience now on the floor
one-year-old muhammad has been given a
nasal tube to feed him urgently needed
fluids
ward dr abdul rahman says he's afraid of
what could be on the way
the rains are not come early the city
will come wars day by day and the number
of weeks that will be increasing even
hour by hour day by day and we cannot
handle it or we cannot save them
right across the horn of africa they are
bracing themselves for the double impact
of war and famine
the worst drought in 40 years is
combining with the effects of russia's
invasion of ukraine the ball there may
be thousands of miles away from these
markets but it's pushing up the prices
of grain and fuel to unprecedented
levels making the impact of the drought
even worse
the drought now threatens the worst
famine for years camps are already
filling
with people who've lost any means of
supporting their families
the parents are desperate
[Music]
like sofia a few months ago well off by
her standards she's now destitute she's
had to move to the camp after the
drought killed all her livestock
my grandfather was a goat herd my father
was a goat herd i grew up in that life
and ended up with 500 goats and four
camels and they've all been wiped out
i've got nothing now
[Music]
the rains have failed for a fourth year
with no grass left for the goats they
pull leaves from trees to eat
[Music]
but getting food to the people who need
it will be a huge challenge
across the region millions are facing
acute hunger in the worst drought in
over a generation compounded by the war
in ukraine and without massive
international help agencies say hundreds
of thousands will die of starvation
dominic waghorn sky news mandera
somaliland
back at home and it's not just the real
networks facing disruption in the uk
since summer holidays season began
airports across the country have
struggled to cope with the post-lockdown
influx of passengers uh joining us now
is the daily telegraph um
travel editor that's claire irving
regular contributor to the program of
course hi
to see you thanks for joining us shadow
leveling up secretary that's lisa nandy
speaking at the weekend saying chaos at
the ports chaos on the railways chaos at
the airports chaos everywhere you go
yeah couldn't have put it better myself
i mean you know after two years of not
being able to travel
to how to suddenly have to face you know
we've and we've been saying all the way
through you've got to be flexible you've
got to um you know
just
help as much as you can be prepared know
your rights be in touch with your
operator be in touch with the airline
and then to find that actually despite
all of that you might not be able to get
anywhere really is a massive blow for
people just desperate not just to go on
holiday but to be reunited you know
we've still got situations where people
haven't seen friends or family easyjet
again tell us that they're cutting their
flights i know i mean
so i have
i you know given where we are i think
um
future cancellations are actually a
positive move i'm you know i wouldn't
wish that on any passenger
but
yeah if i have a flight booked i'd much
and it's going to be cancelled i'd much
rather know about that two weeks in
advance rather than two hours in advance
which we were seeing over half term
because then at least you have you know
that that really
um
preciously ring fence time off at least
you know you might have half a chance of
being able to go somewhere during that
time um you know it gives you much more
time to um to arrange finances to be
able to claim compensation and make sure
that you've done everything properly
rather than
in a mad last minute panic can't go
anywhere by rail at the moment though
can you if you're planning on going to
the lake district or whatever well again
that's
requiring passengers to have to think on
their feet
know what other options they've got
and you know
i mean it really is going to be a tough
summer for passengers so we're just
saying you know if you want to go
anywhere be prepared we've got all the
advice that you need whether you are
hoping to go by rail hoping to go
by air
or even
hoping to drive
which brings me on to my next point
staycations of course you know they've
been a big thing during the pandemic
yeah but with the cost of fuel are
people in a position where they can
afford to fill up the tank a couple of
times well um good point but also it's
not just fuel we've seen staycation
prices rise exponentially we compared
like for like a holiday in spain with a
holiday in the uk in cornwall and and
the holiday in cornwall guess what a
third more expensive that's three
thousand pounds to the two thousand
pounds it costs in spain
uh so really i mean you know you would
be and also we've seen hoteliers airbnb
owners really really ramp their prices
up since the pandemic since there was
that huge rush for staycation brilliant
weather nobody could go anywhere but the
uk and let's face it the uk is amazing
you know nowhere i think any island has
got such diversity
of options
and and so the good news is actually if
you're thinking of staying in in the uk
there is probably somewhere quite low
relatively local to you
that you maybe haven't thought of so
there are huge
really wonderful opportunities and
alternatives to cornwall um and
depending on where you are in the
country i mean you've got suffolk for
example
lesser explored areas of dorset
um north pembrokeshire county down i
mean you know all around the country
there are these kind of
overlooked honey pots that you you know
you should consider so you talked about
um at least you know your flights cancel
like a fortnight ahead so you you can
plan but we're now hearing that ba cabin
crew are thinking about going on strike
so those we don't know what sort of
strikes there might be there could be
lightning strikes it could be anything
yeah so how can you protect yourself
against that
well i mean in short you can't really
weekend terminal two i mean yeah
and you know and the delays are
horrendous i got caught up in some
delays over half term i mean it is
misery wherever you look and uh
you know traveling particularly
traveling your family traveling trying
to avoid this
by traveling just with hand luggage is
not an option i mean with delays at the
airport your hand luggage is going to be
full of crisps for a start um
but you um
so you you need to we're advising where
possible i know it's slightly more
expensive but travel with a tour
operator because they will
you know they're bound then to get you
to destination and get you back which is
very important obviously um
know your rights have
full insurance
and um and make sure that you you know
if something happens that you claim
compensation
um so that you can rebook you know and
that you're not left um
you know out of pocket as well as so
we'll stay at home instead then um and
we'll go to a festival perhaps but of
course we might not be able to get to
the festival this is the old do you know
who the oldest person is who's playing
at glastonbury um other than mccartney
at 80. he is
yes let's have a quick listen to him
yeah that's not him playing live of
course but we can the beatles are so
difficult to play their music but if
it's just his then you can actually have
a little snippet of it there he is paul
mccartney the oldest at 80. are you are
you a festival's fan
what's your top tips on festivals top
tips well again just be prepared i mean
particularly at the moment going to
glastonbury those roads are going to be
absolute murder so go as early as you
possibly can i would say um and you know
like every at everything go be prepared
you know yulu rolls your water um
although not in a plastic bottle at
rastenbury um you need your refillable
bottle there
and um we endorsed that message there's
no such thing of course as bad wear
they're just the wrong clothes so bear
that in mind as well we've seen people
uh rolling around in mud like
glastonbury year after year that there
is no need to do that yeah although
apparently the weather's going to be
pretty good um yeah this weekend spf
yes spf 50. and a hat yeah are you
planning on going anywhere
um i am
currently considering my options for the
summer and i'm a big fan of
off-peak places and oh because she spoke
to us from oman yeah and i just think i
don't it's not based on science but i
just have a gut instinct that if i'm
going to rajasthan which is um where i
am thinking growing in the summer and
everybody else is going to spain
i you know i just hope that i'm the only
person in that queue
it doesn't always work out that way the
plane goes okay it's great to see you as
always claire thanks very much indeed uh
thanks a lot we've got time to play
billy eilish or not
billy eilish is the youngest to play at
glastonbury
i'm getting old i don't know why she's
got blood around her mouth
i don't know i will see you at the top
of the hour
[Music]